hey guys I'm Ryan right and I'm Jeremy
so we're gonna watch this trailer for a
movie called Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles so pumped right now Colin's hood
memories I saw have you seen in the
trailers yet I've seen one of them yeah
yeah I like the trailer a lot of people
are very much disliked this is very
split amongst audiences of who thinks
it's gonna be good or not okay let's be
honest cause it's not like twenty to
thirty percent of you who don't like it
just cuz Michael Bay produced it yeah
but no if you're not cool with it I get
it but everyone's saying this trails
pretty [ __ ] sick I hear we get to see
little more the bad guy or some [ __ ]
like yes I just want tha yeah please
tell me it's gonna happen now they get
energy from the PISA everything about it
was better but they didn't eat pizza in
the movie and it was it was all mostly
but I would recommend it if they yeah
just had a slice once the ones one slice
all I'm asking for one cheesy yep
[Music]
ah yeah sort of a badass she's driven to
the subway GOC mom a little bit
[Music]
taking
[Music]
right there oh gosh
Donatello no [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
my gosh
Oh
[Music]
a lot of fun looks like a badass good
time oh my gosh [ __ ] Turtles and it's
like in a serious take over there's
still some humor yeah I will admit
though Megan Fox doesn't look like any
special April O'Neil like there's
nothing about her April O'Neil's a
pretty important character and there's
no surprise Michael Bay casted her again
after all the crap factors she did
before a transformer yeah that's right
they made up I mean why else would the
heat get the role yeah I mean seriously
what the [ __ ] she care yeah yeah [ __ ]
movie looks really sick dude like I
loved it here the look of the shredder I
mean yeah there's a robot this time then
no but that's pretty sweet
I was insane it's pretty scary looking
ya know it's this is like a really dark
take of Ninja Turtles
there's a lot of movies lately that's
all they do you know I've been excited
for a while Jeremy's excited I'm so
pumped right now yeah I'm pumped
everywhere yeah feel pretty super right
now you got a good chest thank you
I've never been able to like my chest
like Terry Crews oh no I can't you it's
just like I just look like I'm just
humping something you make them bounce a
little bit oh do ya do be good oh you
wish you could feel that yeah you do
nice shout-out to subscriber Michelle
Fernandez she's pretty hot my boobs
against your boobs
hey guys I can use channel subscribe to
the real rejects and if you have a
subscribe at Jeremy's channel yet
subscribe to his if you want to you know
see him do some awesome dance moves or
learn about health or I can make that
somewhere interesting yeah yeah you know
he taught me today if you actually get
more fit it's easier to get drunk you
can get drunk even faster you know
because people are like oh you're
lightweight but I think lightweights got
it easy cuz every weights they just keep
drinking more to get the same effect the
light weight gets no you drink less you
get drunk faster the cheap date but it's
so worth it yeah that's why I'm gonna
get in shape I've made some shots real
fast
Peter Dickson he is everything
it sounds like you wanted to shout out
so yeah Peter Dickson get that dick he's
a guy you know what it well you know
it's nice to Rohtak yeah maybe if you if
you do want dick good for you man
seriously I don't know how you guys do
it man anal must hurt but if you get
pleasure out of it good for you that's
right straight guys can be selfish oh
you feel about anal but a lot of guys
want to have anal sex well they don't
want anything done to their butts you
know I mean that's true yeah we'll be
hypocritical a little bit hypocritical
of straight men yeah what you gonna do
about it yeah Billy you're a good old
friend finger bottle huh come on Peter
get with it right when you said that I
had a very weird image of that happy
they got really tight okay naked nacks
this is I think you're British or
Australian you're a very pretty girl and
she actually did a trailer reaction to
one of my trailer reactions I want to
see that ya know it's pretty [ __ ]
cool she's got a pretty smile on her
pretty laugh so nice I was watching her
watch me and house thank you
you got some pretty good-sized [ __ ]
next to you by the way pretty next in
hey nak nak see like nasty knickknacks
are nasty
well like in a positive way okay NBA
Lakers nation this dude has been waiting
forever for a shout-out now what
happened was I gave you a shout-out in a
video where the I think the mic wasn't
and yeah then I remember - just give me
one right now sorry about the wait but
dude you comment a lot you keep on
asking for a shout-out so here it is man
just enjoy it and the Lakers that are
cool I'm from LA so bye
so Lakers all the way even though
they're nuts they didn't do too well
last season no man let's pretend it
didn't happen don't worry man Michael
Jordan Scottie Pippen and Dennis Rodman
are gonna pick it up one day